oh man here comes someone oh yeah so we
we're gonna give this uh singing
competition another shot these are all
original cat songs that aren't raps
so oh they're they're all and they're
all king of the sting theme yeah [ __ ]
sick
all right here's a show
about anything
it's a show called the king and the
sting
punk my anchor flawed my aunt
you can do whatever you want
[Music]
that one man fan bro
[Music]
oh this is hotter than that guy's arm
[Music]
all jokes brennen
i love you guys
don't touch me bro
keep touching me bro
[Music]
there we go
even chin's bobbling that head man you
feeling that chin
i like the harmonica and then the beat
somebody needs to give jj reddick a
10-day contract is all i'm saying
aj reddick somebody who likes toby
mcguire back in spider-man up in this
[ __ ]
uh good job man it's incredible yeah
that was cool that guy's playing three
four instruments there yeah you get on
the venice beach they get the one-man
band he's the black dude he'll have the
[ __ ]
shambles on his shoulders he plays the
sax guitar
plays the [ __ ] piano with his feet
really yeah dog
damn he plays a shotgun
he plays a shambles almost
[Laughter]
when i was a kid i grew up on this dude
right there i think he died
it could also be wesley snipes one-man
band in venice beach
yeah i grew up on this dude in the
summers i grew up in venice oh [ __ ] we
always toss this [ __ ]
get it all on our going back to that
what does it say get it all on our sd
store
what the f man where are you going now
tell me if he's better than
that [ __ ] brokeback toby mcguire
he always played michael jackson if i
remember see the feet
and the drums
it's michael jackson
[Music]
is this a guy from the howard stern show
what was that guy's name beetlejuice
yeah see but he'll play that sax too now
any singing
you might have tourette this is giving
meal this this makes me nervous watching
this guy
i think if you get past three
instruments it's too much yeah that was
a real [ __ ]
man when i was a kid i thought he was
the [ __ ] you didn't now i see this grown
man he's
clearly on meth that's garage van that's
before garage baiting right there
back when uh what are you gonna say nick
i was just gonna say that uh the first
one was mark from massachusetts toby
maguire
yeah i think that venice guy was [ __ ]
homeless mark from mass did a good job
yeah he was nice i was i was relaxed to
that yeah very relaxing what do you
think of that
that cat is that your kind of guy you
think that kind of guy
yeah any guy who can multitask and play
a harmonica
good with me you want to slide in the
dms with a song for you
i mean if he does maybe i'll see it i
don't see it
maybe i'll see you maybe yeah
cat ain't even sure about that what's
this alley cat zach brown band got for
us
got that hipster's easy top tattooed ham
some bust lamps
i feel got cheeks and pretty started
[Music]
streaks
the big boy bike club ain't no quitter
get you one of those gray block hitters
brandon looks like he works security
at a limousine service built only for
twins
looks like he lifts weights at a truck
nick's eating their wisconsin cheese
and cats bringing those [ __ ] boys to
their knees
chin's wearing a mask chapelle's playing
hacky in the sun
i am
brandon can't name desserts or cheese
tv shows got that ct
use head lips it ain't no thing just
louisiana boys dreaming out gang gang
tattooed camps and bust lamps
if you've got cheeks and brandon started
streaks
oh dude this is
leave you feeling yourself thank you
brother i appreciate it that was
beautiful
beautiful young man he was great he was
really good man that guy
and look at all that hair on his face
too that's a commitment
yup what's the longest you can grow that
thing you got going hell
jesus this just sucks man you can hate
it bro you're so [ __ ] mad bro
shave i can't why can't you shake it
over and says you like it
really oh [ __ ] i'm just kidding now she
didn't say that
i'm fooling y'all
okay she said it you just don't want to
do it no she's
does she like it or not yes she does but
i hate it brother that's all patched up
and [ __ ] bro look like
it's a patchy it's it's a patchy it's a
little yeah
i mean i'm not one to talk my beard's
not great either but
you should shave and should be like deal
with it okay
yeah i mean i think if you get it yeah i
think maybe shave it up
i mean a haircut wouldn't kill you now i
like it you growing it out it doesn't
look bad growing it out but if you try
and get a haircut you got to quit with
all this
all the corona cause i know a ton of
barbers out there you do then tell me
bruh
drop these names oh damn i text you all
the time you don't text me
you never touch i know that's right
you're right you're right you're you're
millionaires you put on some weight
i didn't put on the weight broken
i get all defensive whenever he talks
about my weight put on some white
and the last guy was dan lucille and
this is jack hutchinson you talked to me
dan he he had me feeling
good dan made me proud to do this show
really yeah that's true that's how i
felt good called about that
let's seed it let's see you know let's
see this little don
boy are you crazy this boy don't jack
off the wonder woman comments this is a
coconut donut
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and he's lucky that he's
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Music]
you won't see this [ __ ] on the news
oh king at the sting
brandon says he's not gay but he really
loves shoes
you can't be a sneaker hannah
yeah dude oh yeah i wish you would lick
his lips more darling
[Music]
like
[Music]
i feel like his dad's saying this then
he's over cats he's looking really
fine a lot of weirdos in your dm
[Music]
one of those kids that's born without a
liver you know and they
yeah he grew up in the psych ward or
some [ __ ] no
without a liver you don't go to the
psych ward i know how they do it man
this skit seems a little off
it was a very joe exotic vibe he sampled
the song a little bit i think it was the
same beat but
yeah same vibe that was good that's
crazy the voice was that deep no one no
one beats that hipsters easy top though
that [ __ ] was fire
yeah daniel lucille what's his name yeah
daniel lucille daniel lucille yeah
nobody gets real daniel lucille came
through with that hitter right there
and that right here and credits for the
episode oh yeah
and that one right there i feel like was
good if you're
yeah if you're leaving your wife or
something and driving out of town i'd
listen to that one
but if you're doing something else i'd
listen to something else that's fair
you know but good submissions though man
those were really good only
yeah what do you think chan you're the
musical man here
i'm with brennan the second guy he's
seen he has like an older soul
countries yeah he seemed friendly yeah
not the big the big boy didn't at the
end but you know what i'm getting that
[Music]
yeah